hannah is with us in Tennessee hey
Hannah welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up I am wanting to start
school again and my husband and I are in
baby steps - we did SVU back in February
and I was just wanting some advice on
whether I should start in January or if
I should push that off and wait until
we're a little bit more financially
stable as we're digging out of this hole
so I watch your household income right
now it's between 92 and 95 thousand okay
what are you going to study sports
exercise a movement science I want to
become a physical therapist you starting
from scratch no I have two and a half
years and I just it'll take about two
more years free to finish okay what will
that cost
it'll cost me twenty four thousand to
finish but I know that I qualify for
grants and whatever else remaining we
plan to pay out of pocket and hopefully
I can qualify for some scholarships not
real listening to the debt-free degree
good
so what grants have you guys that you
know you've got how much well I don't
know the amount yet I just fill out my
FAFSA but I know from past I was able to
get the Pell grant and that was about
four thousand a semester why would you
get the Pell Grant when you make 90
thousand a year
well this is my first time going back to
school after or making that much money
so I'm waiting so my FAFSA to see how
much I qualify oh you don't qualify for
a Pell Grant make a 90 K it's for poor
people okay okay so okay 24,000 let's go
with that what do you make now my
husband makes 80 what do you make now I
personally make 12 to 15 as a freelancer
I stay home with our two toddlers okay
and so you're going to work full-time as
a PT I'm hoping - yeah okay you'll put
your kids in daycare
yes there'll be an elementary school by
that time yes okay and what does a PT
get paid
I know starting out they can make around
sixty but that really depends on where
you get a job how much debt do you all
have not counting your house we have a
hundred and two thousand and debt right
now on what sixty four thousand and
student loans twenty four thousand and
cars and twenty-nine and credit cards
what's your projection on that being
clear Megan ninety we're hoping to be
finished within the next 24 months okay
then doing the school delays that by
year well we just assumed that we'd be
paying more for child care and also if
there's any money that we're having to
pay out of pocket for school because we
want to avoid taking out more student
loans so that could take out of what we
would pay towards that yeah so twenty
four thousand added to the top of the
depth of one hundred and two that you've
already got making ninety if you can do
ninety in two years it's going to take
you three years I mean if you can do 102
in two years it's gonna take you three
years to get everything done if you do
the school okay that makes sense
yes so I should start school in January
so I'm delaying it if you cash flow it
okay no loans okay and then you stay on
your budget and you don't use school as
an excuse to lay off your baby step two
you still got a lien in the baby step
two and you got a knock got dead out
okay three years from today you should
graduate debt-free and be debt-free
other than your house okay that's the
math we just did yeah and your family's
got to all be on board with that your
husband you you got to be cuz this is
gonna require you're really not gonna
get anything else done in the next three
years you're gonna have zero life you're
gonna go to school and pay debt right
that's it
no vacations you're certainly not going
to see the inside of a restaurant I mean
there's no wiggle room in this it's kind
of willing to do all of that the return
on investment here 24,000 n 60,000 out
makes sense meaning you spend 24 to go
make 60 and you're paying cash that
makes sense and I would do it but you
just what you're saying is you're
putting it you're you're choking the the
hose on your on your budget flow right
yeah and we're just admitting that and
we're looking at the actual arithmetic
on that and saying it's basically an
extra year so I think the irony is is
that you'll finish school and that at
about the same time okay perfect go do
it thank you thank you appreciate the
call